[Music]
what's happening there reject nation the
whip thwip and i gotta thank all you
thwippers out there cause the amount of
social media messages i got yesterday i
was like
what
nah what
and i listen to this stuff she got [ __ ]
[Laughter]
so if you guys don't know there's going
to be some spoilers in here all right
this is leaked every leak you got to
take with a grain of salt but once you
start seeing a bunch of videos on
twitter youtube and then it extends to
google drive and dropbox
being taken down
like oh damn this must be real
this must be very real verifiable leak
right there so if you guys haven't heard
the soundtrack for spider-man no way
home we don't have it but it did leak
and then i gotta listen to a good amount
of it before it got taken off the
internet yeah there's some big reveals
here so i wanted to talk a little bit
about my experience when listening to
track 19 specifically
and then there's also titles for the
tracks out there now the titles all i
saw was like i got a screenshot of what
the titles were but it didn't look like
they were from like the back of a cd or
something it looked like they're from
someone's notes so i'm not 100 sure if
those are real or not but it seems
likely yeah
it certainly matches a lot of the plot
leaks we've seen and then there's a
couple of them that i wish that didn't
know the titles for so when we go
through the titles and warnings there's
going to be some major major spoilers
there and we will give a heads up when
we start going through the titles if you
want to not watch that part because yeah
the titles have some big ones we're
going to focus on just a few of those
tracks but guys so when i got word it
was like you're going to want to listen
to track 19 you're going to want to
listen to track 19. i didn't know the
title of it at the time when i was
listening to it and here's a little bit
of a spoiler suddenly started hearing
toby maguire's theme song coming in
you're coming in
creeping in there with the tom hollands
then then uh it hit me like minutes
later i'm so used to having a camera
pointed at me when i'm surprised or
shocked or shot with excitement that i
start to tear up that i forget about the
times this happens to me when a camera's
not pointed at me
because yeah there's no way in hell we
can play this in a video but my personal
experience when i that tune instantly
started coming in because i just
re-watched the spider-man reimu films i
recognized right away i just went oh and
my eyes shot red
it was beautiful absolutely beautiful
and i listened to a lot of the
soundtrack this is a powerful soundtrack
this is like pure michael gee gee i'm
still
this is pure michael giaccino i'll be
completely frank with you i wasn't all
that impressed with the spider-man
homecoming or spider-man far from home
soundtracks there's a lot of mcu movies
that have a well-regarded soundtrack a
welcome regarded score for the most part
you kind of they don't really stand out
this album is solid this the music here
kept giving me chills i love the hell
out of it i think it's one of the best
scores i've heard so far for people
saying like it could be fake maybe
that's a lot of it's a great talented
work that you have to do to face this
thank you baby
yeah because this is amazing stuff man
and it's it just reminds me of like
great michael giaccino scores for sure
so for sure and track 19 you're hearing
toby mcguire's theme and track 23 i was
hearing more of the andrew garfield
theme i'm going to be completely honest
with you guys the james horner music i i
don't recall as well i had to actually
listen to that theme song and then go
back to track 19 to 23. like is that
where it is where's my mind just
thinking that's where it is yeah because
yeah the original danny elfman scores
for sam raimi are so ingrained in my
mind even
not withstanding having revisited the
film recently but like yeah those are so
heavily set and the ones to come after
it did not leave as heavy an impression
on me so i did have to do some comparing
contrast yeah but i'm pretty sure
they're both in there yeah for sure you
hear a combination of all them but john
you heard it what do you think
absolutely i mean it really goes along
it's funny everyone was like track 90
track 19 track 19. and i was expecting
okay this has to be like the big
convergence crossover track but what
struck me about the pieces of this i've
heard including track 19 is that level
of heft and drama and even air like
there are times when yeah like the music
does swell and it does get you know
soaring or even triumphant but there's a
lot of it that is really tense intensity
and yeah tense and intense and and
hearkens to something that is going to
be emotionally sort of heavy and
harrowing and i was sitting there
listening going man i mean we're all
gonna be like excited and losing our
minds if and when i'm gonna say when in
light of all this you know the other two
show up but now it got me kind of
thinking like that's probably also going
to be probably like a moment of intense
desperation or something like that to
where they really do feel like they're
here to not only give us like the fan
expectation we've always wanted but to
save the day to help in a dire situation
and yeah that was the most striking
thing it's like tom holland and various
other people have talked about this is
gonna be the most harrowing movie for
peter parker i definitely buy that based
off the excerpts out of the score that
i've heard thus far i didn't hear all of
it but a lot of the tracks that i did
here i was very much surprised by just
how it was getting my imagination going
yeah it's very evocative yeah but guys
let's go through some titles i didn't
expect there to be such big spoilers in
the titles one of them i was even a
little bit of something like what would
you even put that on the like what would
you what would you call it that if that
is this is indeed the title why would
you call it that first things first
track 19 the one everyone's talking
about supposedly is titled spider-man
that confirms
like not only just hearing the pieces of
music it's not just an homage it's
called spider-man meaning the spider-man
what else are you putting multiple
spider-man the word because it's
interesting when you look at the track
numbers that comes after like statue of
liberty but there's also another track
called science bros yeah and we were
hearing that upon introduction with them
the chemistry that you'll see forming
with them is mainly based off of them
doing science together and not so much
doing spider-man fighting together i
don't know where science first would
refer to you know ned and and peter as
they were in like spider-man homecoming
when they're buddying up so i'm not sure
but yeah so you have this one called
spider-man and there's another track
track 12 called sinister which i was
surprised by because i thought for sure
we'd be getting just sinister five so
maybe perhaps this is alluding to
sinister six
and then the big one that i was like wow
i i can't believe they titled that i
mean this is heavily rumored but you
might have heard us touch on this a few
times in videos track 13 was called maze
death which could only mean one thing
and the following track is called
sadness yeah
just to drive it okay
sure
yeah
kind of a lazy title yeah a lot of
sadness
depression
mourning i think would have been maybe a
little bit better i mean again if this
is the real track listing i guess i am a
bit surprised by the bluntness of that
although given other soundtracks i've
bought they can cues can be titled that
way and i guess the thing that would
shock me most is if they put out an
official release where that doesn't get
changed because of how under wraps and
tight this movie has been kept i haven't
heard that theme as of yet i haven't
heard either yet
i'm very i'm anticipating it for sure
but it is a little bit like oh damn
because we look at the full track list
um which i'm a little too afraid to show
on camera right now but if you look at
the full track list it does seem like
this is the structure of what we all
sort of imagine how it would go the plot
structure of how i i thought like yeah
when you look at the trailer scenes this
all lines up really well but the biggest
one is track 23 called welcome the x-men
yes
xavier's sweet
[Laughter]
yeah it's gonna be great i still don't
know how it's i only know plot beats i
don't really know the the execution of
how it's all gonna go down i don't know
how this is gonna end i have no idea
what the hell doctor strange is talking
about when he says they're gonna comment
i have no idea what he's referring to oh
yeah yeah it's good to have at least a
little mystery still left yeah and i
mean yeah you were right like if you go
through the track list you can kind of
surmise the structure of the movie and
there's a track called need some help
yeah that precedes you know those motifs
all coming together so you can you can
kind of pick it out but even like uh
even when you go through the last half
of the tracks other than like the
obvious plot points of like yeah the
spider-man are going to come in and
stuff like the biggest one is mace at
them
it tells me nothing about what's going
to happen at the end
yeah i have no idea what's going to
happen this is a crazy ass leak it
confirms a lot confirmed one big plot
point 100 confirms toby and andrew this
is absolutely major and then perhaps the
sinister six too just called sinister
yeah maybe they'll borrow some music
from the film sinister alright guys
leave your thoughts down below thank you
so much for jumping on in here hey we'll
catch you guys soon